thank you Michael for that wonderful
introduction so today I'm gonna be
talking about designing social computing
systems that support collective action
by centering trust and familiarity and
I'll talk about how these systems help
people build strong networks as well as
provide support to move efforts forward
when they stall and I'm going to be
presenting this work that I did together
with accessibility advocates on Mozilla
as well as worker rights advocates on
Amazon Mechanical Turk but I'd like to
start with a vignette from an effort
that's going on and I've been involved
in I was the parts of an observer and it
has to do with harassment on Twitter
this includes things like death and rape
threats that are unfortunately very
common but are frequently used in a
concerted way to silence people and this
is an issue that many people have very
strong feelings about and they have and
they're determined to act on and they
have taken some actions so for instance
there's a change.org petition asking
Twitter to shut down accounts that tweet
threats and it has almost 400,000
signatures and the actress Rose McGowan
actually spoke out about against Harvey
Weinstein's sexual harassment for the
first time on Twitter and her account
was suspended this caused a lot of
outrage because people were upset that
hate speech on the platform even where
reported a lot of the time goes
unchecked and then when someone's
actually speaking out against harassment
they're the one who got shut down so a
couple people tried to organize a
boycott in response they chose a hashtag
women boycott Twitter they chose a date
and they broadcasted the event through a
quite a number of high-profile
celebrities but the effort itself was
controversial
some people boycotted the boycott other
people made counter hashtags such as
women of color affirmation Twitter
promised to make changes but they also
said they have limited resources and the
whole effort sort of fizzled why I'm
going to argue that there were two main
reasons for this the first is a lack of
trust in the action so especially among
women of color or trans women who felt
like they were all of a sudden so
expected to participate in a boycott
they hadn't received similar support
when they talked about their issues one
person said if this is the event that
activated your awareness I don't
particularly trust you and the other
reason that it stalled was that because
there was friction among people who were
potential supporters of the effort about
for instance whether a boycott was an
appropriate way to protest the silencing
of women I'll come back to the specific
issue on Twitter at the end of my talk
but what I wanted to demonstrate here
more generally was that even highly
motivated collectives when facing these
kinds of open-ended complex challenges
often fail to envision shared outcomes
and act on them together and to unpack
this a bit these groups of people with
shared issues are very similar to the do
in formation of publics that is used by
DeSalvo the Don take and it's it's
rooted in theories of democracy talking
about groups rallying around shared
issues that affect them what
differentiates these particular groups
that we're talking about here is that
they're also acting together so they're
doing the work of coordination and
collaboration deciding or arguing
between alternative paths to take and
they're also facing failure and this is
because of the nature of the challenges
that they face these are challenges that
are messy interdependent and they sound
a lot like wicked problems wicked
problems is a phase that originally came
out of urban planning but it's also
frequently used in design thinking to
talk about these kinds of problems that
are difficult or even impossible to
solve because there are just too many
moving parts and the problem itself
changes as you try to solve it so it
makes the goal and the path to get to it
unclear so what I'm proposing and the
stuck is designing to support publics
working together on these kinds of
wicked problems and we know from prior
literature that the basis for group to
be able to work on a wicked problem
together is that they need to know each
other and trust one another familiarity
is a term that I'm going to use a lot in
this talk and it's a term coming out of
social psychology and organizational
behavior that describes how well two
people know each other for instance it
can be measured by how long have they
been working together in the past and
this is really important for collective
action because
familiar groups start to learn each
other strengths and weaknesses they
develop situated knowledge about who
knows what and that enables them to
strategize and coordinate action
familiarity can also lead to Trust which
increases psychological safety people
groups with high psychological safety
are more comfortable taking risks
together and finally these kinds of
familiar grips tend to share knowledge
sharing knowledge leads to collective
sense making and can lead to the
development of the shared identity which
is also very important so for these
collectives that have shared issues it's
for them to be able to act together they
need familiarity and Trust but rather
than build that the existing
infrastructure that we have is designed
around these it's designed around
increasing these engagement metrics so
it's designed around atomic fast paced
interactions and I see how literature
has actually found that the thing that
on social media actually increases Thai
strength is having conversations with
each other but on the other hand if you
think about what is rewarded right now
on the current design of Twitter it's
these things that are instant likes
retweets things that get a lot of
attention or sensational and so in doing
so the social environments that we've
built actually incentivize fly-by
disagreements and things that are
sensational and disincentivized actual
difficult conversation so my main goal
in this talk is going to be designing
alternative environments that scaffold
and guide social interactions toward
building networks that can help groups
form publics around issues and work
together on the wicked problems that
they face so how are we going to do that
I'm going to show through two projects
that I worked on here during my PhD so
the first step is to bring a group
together and help them build networks of
familiarity so what we want to do is
encourage people to talk to the same
small group of people over over time so
that they get to know each other but at
the same time we want to balance this
with reaching out and having
conversations with new people who bring
diverse perspectives so I want to do the
work of building a network and that's
the goal of my first project hive which
I did
with accessibility advocates on Mozilla
but even when you have that even when
you have those networks of familiarity
efforts can still get stuck
for instance when there are
disagreements and I've worked on
designing structured human support that
can move efforts forward when they stall
and I'll talk about that in the context
of my project dynamo which was a
collaboration with worker rights
advocates on Mechanical Turk through
these two projects what I want to do is
convince you that if we pay particular
attention to a collectives relationships
of trust we can actually design social
computing systems that assist that
collective and acting together and just
as a heads up these two projects have
very different methodologies so in the
first part of the talk when I talk about
the project hive I'm going to define a
model of human behavior and then I'm
going to design algorithms and we
actually built a real-world system that
produced new kinds of social
arrangements and then what we actually
studied those new arrangements through
controlled experiments and a field
deployment in the second half of the
talk when I talk about dynamo we took a
grounded theory approach and we
developed these concepts out of
ethnographic study and code design with
the people we were designing with so
first I'll talk about hive and here
we're mostly talking about the early
stages of collective action you have a
group of people they have some kind of
shared issue that they all care about
and people are trying to do the work of
deliberation understanding and
articulating what exactly the problem is
and collectively imagining goals and
paths forward to alternative futures and
what I'm going to present is this
concept of network rotation which is a
computational model that organizes
conversations between these people so it
balances how strong people's ties are to
the people they're talking to at each
point with who they're talking to and
how tightly knit the overall network is
so what we're trying to do with this
concept of network rotation is trying to
get people to share their ideas but also
be exposed to different kinds of
perspectives all while keeping the
psychological safety of the group of
people who are talking to each other at
each point hi
I'll explain what this all means but
first I wanted to remind us of what the
current social computing infrastructure
that we have and how it works so usually
what happens when a group of people have
a shared problem is that each person
comes and they say the first thing that
comes to their mind so in the case of
harassment on Twitter you might have
someone thinking that in response we
should all boycott Twitter for a day
someone else might think but well we
should actually all share our stories
for a day and another person might think
that the best path of action is actually
to start recording abuse create a list
of harasser and record it and these
ideas are often very different they're
also often not very good by themselves
because they fail to incorporate other
people's viewpoints experiences and
constraints and because of this drawback
HCI literature has actually looked into
the different ways that we can encourage
people to engage with each other and
intermix their ideas usually the way
these systems are designed is that we
will have a big gallery or map of
everyone's ideas and then we'll go to
the person who came up with the boycott
idea for instance and show them the
recording idea and say enter mix these
two ideas often what happens is that the
person who came up with the boycott idea
will come back and say no my idea was
better and the reason for this drawing
on research and communication theory and
organizational behavior is that in the
real world just having exposure to other
people's ideas doesn't actually
influence us that much and we're much
more influenced by other people's
viewpoints when we talk to them the
reason for this is that knowledge is
situated and it's actually developed in
the context of our social relations so
instead of intermixing ideas I propose
to intermix people in one study
researchers showed that when they had
these real-world teams working on a
creative task they they had these teams
working separately on the task and then
they took a piece of paper from a team
asked them to write their ideas down and
they showed it to another team and that
actually had no effect on the outcome
they just ignored it but when they did
the same study and they
moved a person from the first team to
the second one it actually significantly
improved the team's output so what we
know is that engaging in these kinds of
conversations with people can lead to
better ideas that dig deeper into the
problem and this is the insight that
this project hive is based on but what
we want to do is make this possible at
the scale of a big network so I'm going
to propose what I've termed network
rotations instead of having everyone in
the collective talk to everyone at the
same at the same time what it's going to
do is divide people into teams
so people are in these smaller groups
where they actually get to have a
conversation with each other and get to
know one another and then it's going to
iteratively weave people together from
different parts of this network what
it's trying to do here is facilitate the
spread of distant viewpoints within the
collective there are many many different
ways to do this to reorganize this
network in a way and what we want to do
is do this intelligently or effectively
so the first question we need to ask is
what are the conditions for an effective
network rotation we already talked about
one of them at the beginning of the talk
familiarity which increases
psychological safety and I've actually
worked on research that used a dynamic
programming algorithm to optimize for
highly familiar teammates when we didn't
know individual availability for each
person but the challenge with that is
that we don't want to always talk to the
same people over and over we want people
to engage with these kinds of diverse
perspectives from people who have maybe
thought about the problem differently
than we have so I'm going to hypothesize
that balancing these two needs will
actually be more effective than
strategizing to maximize either and I'm
going to show you how the network
rotation algorithm actually does that it
balances familiarity which we measure in
the network as the tie strength between
every two people and the structure of
the network which we measure as network
efficiency and I'm going to show you
through two deployments that we did that
by using network rotation teams
submitted better proposals it didn't
reduce psychological safety and it was
actually used by Mozilla's accessibility
advocates for a week-long design drive
so first I'll talk about hives Network
rotation and then the results of our
controlled experiment and field
deployment so again the core technical
contribution of this work is the concept
of network rotation what it does is
manage membership of teams by
iteratively weaving people from
different parts of the network I'll walk
you through first what that would
actually look like in practice so when
you first join a project on hive the
algorithm will add you to a small team
of three to five people it was really
important for us in deploying the system
to make it a usable buy in the real
world for people so we decided to use
existing tools that people were already
familiar with
so we developed hive as a slack app
which is a chat software and also gives
people the option of being anonymous so
based on the team that you were assigned
to by hive you will get added to a slack
channel for that team and you'll start
working with those people and then at
some point hive decides that it wants to
expose your group to a distant
perspective so it might swap out one of
your teammates for someone new who was
on another team the way it does this in
practice is that there's a slack bot it
will come to your team and announce that
we're moving this person out and this
other person may be moving in and that
it actually performs the move so now you
have a new team and you continue working
with this new team and by the end of the
day the algorithm might decide to make
another set of moves and as you're
probably seeing by now there are many
many different ways to do these
rotations and it gets way more
complicated when you have more than just
four teams so to do this the network
rotation algorithm needs to decide when
to make rotations who to move and where
to move them to and there is an
exponentially large number of possible
solutions so to do this we modeled the
whole collective as a weighted graph tie
strengths in that graph is a familiarity
between every two people who are on the
same team together at that point so if
this is the network these are the teams
what we really care about is the tie
strength between people who are on the
same team together the other thing we
care about is the general network
structure
so this is modeled as Network efficiency
this relates to how closely knit the
network is our hypothesis is that if we
are going to make this disruption move a
new person onto a team it's better to do
this effectively and doing this from
with someone who's in a distant part of
the network will probably be better than
someone who's close by and this is based
on literature and organizational
behavior people sometimes in
organizations talk about this in the
context of structural holes within a
network so for instance if you have
these two networks they have the exact
same number of edges but their structure
is different the way we measure this is
that if you take two nodes in the graph
and you measure the shortest path
between them and then you average this
over all of the pairs of nodes in the
graph you'll get a measure of network
efficiency so that's the average
pairwise shortest path between every two
people so given these two metrics that
we know we care about we want an
algorithm that actually balances them we
usually balance things with optimization
functions we can also turn this into a
weighted sum so that that gives us some
more power over which of these metrics
we care more about so to explain what
this means if we set alpha to 1 in this
in this optimization function what that
means is that I only care about tie
strength I don't care about what the
network looks like and that will give us
an algorithm that won't move anyone
anywhere and it always you'll always
stay with the same people if we set
alpha to 0 that means that all I care
about is network structure I don't care
about how strongly tied the people who
are on the same team are so that will
mean that the algorithm will constantly
be moving people around you'll get a
very network with a lot of edges but all
of those ideas will be pretty weak what
we will actually want is to balance
these two so find a middle ground where
most of the time you're working with
people you know pretty well but then you
also have these a small number of
disruptions over time so now that we
know what the objective is how does the
algorithm work
so the algorithm needs to decide at each
point who it's going to move if if any
and we're there where we want to move
them to so assume that this is the
network we choose the algorithm chooses
one person and wants to move them to
another team
and it wants to know what's the value of
this move should I make this move or not
well you can actually make the move see
how much better the algorithm ization
function is after you made the move and
then see whether you want to do it or
not so what's the value of this move now
that but we don't want to have just one
move we want to have more so we
calculated the value of the first move
now if we want to try a second move we
want to calculate the value of the
second move the value that we calculated
first will no longer be valid because
the network will look different so we
need to because one of the assumptions
that we made knows no longer valid we
can't keep doing these same simple
calculations over time and that's what
makes this problem difficult to solve
there is an exponential number of
possible solutions and as we're going
team composition keeps changing so it's
impossible to know what the value of a
single move is I've proposed a
stochastic search algorithm but tries to
do this so it chooses the best subset of
move it moves at each point and it
calculates the value of that subset of
moves so at each point instead of doing
one move and seeing how much is how much
value it has it takes a whole subset of
moves and sees what the value of all of
those moves together is and then it
loops over time trying lots of as many
subsets of moves as it possibly can and
it has random resets so that it doesn't
get stuck in local Maxima so that's how
the algorithm works hive of the system
as I mentioned is a slack app it manages
team membership hive can also provide
structure to a conversation because it's
a slack app so in in our deployments we
actually followed one iteration of the
design process to help guide people and
what to talk about each day that they
were in this project and what the goal
of each phases so there was a one day
for empathizing one day for defining the
problem and they went through this
process and they were given instructions
for what to talk about as well as
sometimes deliverables to help guide
them so our goal with hive was to
organize conversations that lead to more
effective collective action and the
first thing we wanted to do is control
for as much as we could and see whether
this was actually effective so we wanted
to isolate the effects of
work rotation we recruited 115 Amazon
Mechanical Turk workers to do this we
gave them a prompt that was how can we
design neighborhood comments to be a
place to bring people together to foster
community and mutual aid and we tried to
choose a prompt that a lot of people had
experienced with already and we actually
took a rubric from open idea to to
measure the proposals at the end and we
randomly assigned these people to one of
three conditions so the first condition
the control condition was when we had no
moves at all so that's the same as when
I showed you that graph when alpha was 1
we were maximizing tie strength in the
other condition we maximize network
efficiency not constrained by tie
strings so that's when we were doing
lots of moves and trying to make a very
efficient network and finally Network
rotation was our algorithm so we
compared these three scenarios to do
this teams went through five phases of
the design process in two days and to
measure how well they did at the end we
hired a design expert to actually rate
the proposals based on a rubric that we
gave them what we found was that network
rotation actually improved over the
baseline in the control condition but
never efficiency didn't this suggest
that we want moves that Factory in the
structure of the network we don't want
to just be doing moves but one thing
that we still worried about even though
these network rotation was actually
resulting in better proposals was that
maybe it made people feel less
comfortable contributing because we are
causing some disruption by moving a
teammate off of your team or adding
someone new into the team so we looked
at a measure that's often used for this
psychological safety and we wanted to
see whether psychological safety
actually decreased so psychological
safety is a measure and frequently used
in organizational behavior and it's
about measuring the ability of teams to
take risks it's a strong cartlett with
team performance and it's been validated
in a number of different scenarios it's
a standard survey that has questions
like members of this team are able to
bring up problems and tough issues or
working with members of this team my
unique skills and talent
our valued and utilized so when we give
people the survey psychological safety
it gives us back a score out of zero
from zero to fifty and what we wanted to
measure is whether psychological safety
of these teams suffered when they went
through network rotation so the first
thing we looked at is the survey
responses between people who were on
static teams versus teams who had had a
member join or leave and what we found
was that psychological safety didn't
really suffer from the moves there's one
group who was actually not in this not
in this graph right now and those are
the actual people who were moving so if
you were taken off of the team you're on
and added to a new team and for those
people we saw that psychological safety
did actually go slightly down the reason
for this is that as people became
attached to their ideas and the people
they were working with it was more
difficult for them to reintegrate into a
team later on in the process and what
this shows is that's like that network
rotation is actually costly and it's
important that when we do do it we do it
effectively so we shove the network
rotation as effective but another thing
we wanted to know is what people
actually do this in the real world so we
partnered up with Mozilla's open
innovation team they issued an open call
to their communities of volunteers and
accessibility enthusiasts asking them to
participate in a week-long online design
drive the goal of this was to reimagine
what an accessible web browsing
experience can look like we also reached
out and offered people with disabilities
or people were caregivers to someone
with a disability a $150 gift card to
participate in their project because we
wanted this design drive to be actually
grounded in people's real world
experiences and these people were added
as team lead so each team had at least
one of these people this was a week-long
online effort that actually took a lot
of time and we had very little attrition
so out of the I think 120 people who
participated only six people dropped out
by the end
and on average teams posted about 1,000
lines of chat a day
this give you a sense of the kinds of
proposals that came up by the end I'll
show you two of them so this first one
is about ways of interacting with a
computer that is similar to sign
language and actually one of the members
of this team knew sign language and what
they were saying is that within
communities of people who sign they're
consistently reconfiguring gestures to
mean new things and they wanted a way to
be able to teach the computer what these
new gestures mean or come up with with
ones that they wanted to use frequently
so for instance a specific gesture that
was the name of a friend could mean send
an email to that friend or nodding your
head could mean save the document
another one was about reactive
interfaces so interfaces that I realized
when you're having trouble with them and
sort of react to make it easier to do
the thing you're trying to do so for
instance if they figured out that you
tried to click on a button a couple
times and weren't able to maybe they
could make that button larger to make it
easier especially for people who have
motor problems all of these 86 proposals
were reviewed by Mozilla's accessibility
team who was independent of our study
and they gave the group's feedback on
their proposals they were they chose for
that they were really interested in and
they're continuing to work on those
proposals so what I wanted to talk about
now briefly is what we learned during
this process so when we did this in the
real world one of the things we learned
is that participants told us that new
members brought fresh perspectives and
they allowed for more ideas to come into
the room one of the participant said
meeting new people was great mixing
ideas was very helpful especially as
people dropped in and out later in the
week and while fresh perspectives were
exciting and helpful people also showed
concern about losing on ties that they
had already built with the old team one
person said I liked bringing fresh ideas
and every day it gave a different or new
perspectives but I but sometimes you
build good working relationship with
people and you don't want to lose them
and this result against demonstrates the
importance of balancing tie strengths
with network efficiency
and one way to mitigate this might be to
give teams more control over when they
actually want to participate and member
and membership rotation or not and
finally we found that the anonymity that
hive afforded in these in which was not
which is not common in these kinds of
design design drives actually made
people more comfortable to share those
stories so it increased psychological
safety by creating an environment where
people actually trusted enough to share
one of our participants who had a
disability said wow that didn't even
feel like an hour I'm loving this
this is stuff I never talked about it's
helping me realize some things about
myself that I was blind to before I
started this before I started talking
about it here thank you all so with hive
I just demonstrated that it's possible
to create these kinds of environments
that enable collectives to come together
and build familiarity and generate plans
and proposals hive was designed
specifically for groups who had a shared
issue but didn't know each other yet
dynamo in contrast the second project
that I'm going to talk about was
designed for and by people who did know
each other and familiarity was actually
contributing to the problem this is the
kind of problem that we couldn't
formulate like we did for hive we
couldn't formulate and design an
algorithm for in fact I'm going to argue
through the second part of the talk that
the kind of work that it required could
not actually be written into code and
instead we actually used structured
human labor so what I'm gonna do is move
from an algorithm heavy section of the
talk and move into one that's rooted and
qualitative work and participatory
design and to present dinamo I'm going
to go back to the argument that I made
at the very beginning of the talk that
many collective action efforts online
never succeed and why we already went
through one of the reasons why that
might happen which was a lack of
familiarity and Trust but friction can
still happen despite familiarity the
collective that we worked with in this
scenario I'm Zone Mechanical Turk worker
is also known as Turkish consisted of
multiple tightly knit communities and
they had experienced disagreement and
animosity in the past they even had a
name for it in their community of
practice they called it mega drama so
with dynamo what we wanted to see was
how can we support collective efforts
despite these problems that people had
so I engaged with Amazon Mechanical Turk
workers in the communities that they had
a series of forums and chat rooms I did
a year of ethnographic field work that
they've been my understanding of the
kind of work environment that they had
and the challenges that they faced
but this also enabled me to build a
working relationship with them then
together we designed an employed dynamo
so I'm gonna start talking about dynamo
by talking about the challenges of
online work so what are the what were
the set of shared issues that these
people had that brought them together
and then I'm gonna talk about our effort
to address it dynamo I'll explain common
failure scenarios that happened and the
specific kinds of organizing and
emotional labor that it took to move
these efforts wort success this is work
that we've termed the labor of action
and I'll explain its mechanisms in more
detail so researchers have argued that
crowd sourcing platforms create these
computational infrastructures that make
the crowd workers actually seem
invisible so as a result there's a whole
labor market online that has emerged
that leaves many workers struggling to
find good work or to assert their rights
when they're mistreated and are in
response to that Turkish have actually
formed collectives using web forums and
chat cell for it and they use a lot of
these communities to share a good work
or to talk to employers or even to raise
money when someone needs it what I found
in my ethnography was that these forms
were more effective at coordinating the
kinds of efforts that people wanted to
do when the effort itself was not
controversial and when individual action
still had an effect but they struggled
more when the goal or how to get to it
wasn't clear or when it was an effort
that actually needed many
to share the burden what I found was
that Turkish actually talks a lot about
the issues that they faced but they had
trouble taking the next step and this is
essentially the same problem as Twitter
users faced when they have they faced
friction over strategy and tactics and
it actually caused the whole effort to
fizzle so how can we support an online
collective not just to discuss but to
agree on a common goal and execute in
our effort to try to answer this
question was dynamo so our process for
designing dynamo was interactive and
iterative it involved almost 100 people
and we began by engaging with truckers
on forums publishing surveys on
Mechanical Turk having lots of
conversations with people and then at
the beginning of a few a few talkers
showed more interest and slowly as we
progressed that engaged more people
dynamo itself is an online forum that
supports the Amazon Mechanical Turk
community to form collectives and around
shared issues and mobilize and to show
you how it works I'll again walk you
through one scenario this this it was an
event that was actually triggered by a
well-meaning researcher who injected
false information into Turk optic on
Turk optic honest sort of like the Yelp
for Amazon Mechanical Turk where people
can review review employers
this caused a lot of frustration because
a lot of the trucker's actually relied
heavily on the information on Turk optic
on for their jobs and actually they
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
what had happened where they thought
that it was getting spammed and by the
end of it Turkish agreed that
researchers just lacked exposure to the
kinds of issues and vulnerabilities they
faced this Turkish so this prompted them
to want to write a set of publicly
available ethical guidelines for
research on Amazon Mechanical Turk and
it's communities they imagined that
these guidelines could both be a means
to guide ethical behavior but also to
back Turker claims when things go wrong
so there's this big gap from wanting
ethical guidelines to actually creating
them and having everyone agree on them
and I'll quickly go over the socio
technical infrastructure
that we created for this so dynamo is
based on short ideas which are tweet
lengths pitches it can be a problem it
can be an idea that someone has and then
people can vote up or down on them and
then once an idea gets twenty five up
votes and has more of boatsman downloads
it evolves into a campaign it officially
launches on the front page of the
website and there is various
infrastructure there to support it such
as wiki's and buttons for signing things
so dynamo supports collectives to form
publics around issues and mobilize
publics come together through the shared
conditions that they have or the shared
issues that they have and together they
develop formulations and analyses of
what the problem is and much of the
research on publics actually has focused
on this on what are the conditions for
discourse and assembly we build on on
this work that is heavily rooted and
theories of participatory democracy but
we also take up the conditions by which
these publics consist successfully acts
together and it gets tricky when
shifting from deliberation to action
dynamo efforts almost failed multiple
times they face two common failure
scenarios that we saw and I'm gonna
argue that these two common failure
scenario stalling and friction are
actually common pitfalls that any online
action can fall into and the reason for
this and particularly why we're talking
about online action is that I'm gonna
argue the same decentralized
characteristics that make it very easy
together online also make it very
difficult to actually also make it very
easy to disperse so difficult to stick
together so in other words it's very
easy for someone to walk into a room
where people are having a discussion and
throw a flame it's also very easy for
people to back off and leave solving the
first problem that came up a lot was
when that that exactly happened so the
effort lost momentum and it stops and
this usually happened when the next
steps or how to get to it we're either
difficult to identify or too much work
for a single person to do
and the whole effort lost momentum one
of the efforts on dynamo was a
letter-writing campaign that actually
stalled after weeks of discussion about
how to do this letter-writing campaign
six truckers had written and shared
their letters and the campaign organizer
who was a community manager on a turkey
forum contacted us and said so it seems
no one is interested someone just says
we're doing it wrong but won't say how
to do it right and no one else has any
input but stalling was still in many
ways better than the alternative
friction friction - when there was
active criticism a negative emotion
targeted at the efforts progress for
instance with the guidelines effort that
I mentioned one to occur midway through
expressed disappointment about there was
a certain paragraph in the guidelines
that was not exactly in compliance with
Amazon's Terms of Service so this was
offering guidance about how to use a
very specific kind of screen reading
software that was technically against
the Terms of Service but a lot of people
used it anyway especially for psychology
studies this Turker critique this
position that the guidelines had taken
but then also had general critiques
because they felt like the guidelines
had gotten Mars in technical detail when
it was supposed to be this high-level
document of ethics
so stalling and friction are the twin
pitfalls that I'm gonna argue our
inherent challenges to any kind of
community that acts to avoid stalling
members need to act but acting can
backfire if other people's that if other
people disagree with what you did
causing friction to address friction on
the other hand can reduce motivation and
the people who are getting critiqued and
that caused the stalling so in other
words trying to fix one of these
problems actually often causes the other
and so it seems that online collectives
have far more reasons to fail at acting
together than to succeed when on dynamo
actions faced these pitfalls we steps in
and we performed the labor that we we
thought was necessary to preserve the
forward motion of the movement I'll call
this the labor of action
I'll explain how we did this so as it's
just came up on the website we worked to
help people move past them and gradually
as we were doing this over time we found
that there were common mechanisms that
we kept using so we drill out these
mechanisms we gave them a name so there
we can transfer them to other kinds of
contacts my main contribution in this
work is this idea of the labor of action
which which includes particular kinds of
emotional and cognitive labor that I'm
going to describe and I'm going to argue
that the mechanisms that we use can
actually be also used to catalyze action
other kinds of online communities I'll
describe two of these mechanisms so the
first was debates with deadlines when
friction happened over that one
paragraph in the deadline where some
people wanted other people didn't it
turned into a heated debate that quickly
derailed the whole discussion about the
guidelines and here our role was to
suggest the deadline for that debate
which gave the members involved in the
disagreement reason to find common
ground here's a concrete example of how
we did this so I stepped in in the forum
and I said we've spent so much time and
energy on this we need a last effort to
reach consensus we need your help for
that to happen do you think that setting
a deadline will help one of the people
in that argument responded I do agree
that we should wrap things up soon as
possible without unnecessary sacrifices
another labor of action was act and undo
this specifically helps when there was
stalling so for instance when we
approached the deadline to actually
publish the guidelines there was one
section of the guidelines titled what to
do in cases of violation that remained
untouched no one wanted to write
anything there and here we stepped in
and we actually drafted three emails
that were in the form of templates that
turquois could use to contact
researchers and IRB is in the cases of
violation and this quickly started a
heated debate because some people were
angry that our framing was too
restricting one Turker who was actually
a leader in the guideline effort posted
the purpose of dynamo should be to add
to the rights and resources of terkoz
not
or replace them but our action did get
the effort moving so after some
discussion and editing people were happy
with the end result we call this
mechanism act and undo take action but
leave space for objections and undo your
action if necessary the point here
wasn't for us to do something right the
first try but to do something even if it
was initially perceived as wrong because
this kick starts inertia people are a
lot better at pointing out why something
is wrong than they are at putting out a
proposal in the first place so these are
two of them mechanisms I'm happy to talk
about more in the Q&A but the final
question is did these mechanisms
actually help I'll talk about two of the
efforts that succeeded on the platform
after about a month of work
Turkish finally published to the
guidelines effort on September 7th which
was Labor Day it's available online as a
23-page write-up and it covers different
matters that affect turquoise like fare
payment and respecting Torah privacy
it has 261 signatures so far from
researchers and Turkish and the Stanford
IRB actually uses it to approve research
we've also seen researchers references
the reference this and tasks on
Mechanical Turk and on research papers
another group launched a collective
effort to show the world who tours are
written from their own perspective this
was an open letter writing campaign that
triggers wrote directed to Jeff Bezos
Amazon CEO 30 people posted their
letters publicly that you can read at
this URL and it was covered by major
news outlets including the Guardian and
The Daily Beast and since then Turkish
have actually gone action on two of the
things that they had asked for in their
letters so to conclude dynamo was about
how structured labor the labor of action
can help these movements overcome the
challenges of stalling and friction and
to move forward and what central here is
the fact that the labor of action is not
something that we could have written
into code it requires contextual
knowledge and familiarity with the
members of the public and their goals
some of the actions that people are
taking
here actually risky so it requires
identified trustworthy actors and this I
think challenges the idea that social
software by itself can produce the
conditions for social change and I would
instead encourage us to think about the
ways that centering labor the ways that
we can Center the labor that combined
with software can actually create those
conditions so how can we better support
that labor through software and for the
past few months I've actually been
advising co-worker org which is a non
pop non-profit platform developer for
worker collective action and they're
interested in creating and maintaining
dynamo as an anonymous moderator
platform for worker advocacy in a range
of other kinds of workplaces some of the
open questions here are how do we
actually support the workers who are
doing untrained them to do the labor of
action combined with the software that
they're developing so in this talk I
argued that to support publics working
on wicked problems collectively we need
to design social computing systems that
Center trust and familiarity and through
dynamo and hive I demonstrated that
human labor and computational models are
both important parts of socio technical
systems and to wrap up thinking about
the Twitter example and other kinds of
collective action problems I just want
to note that collective action is hard
complicated and it has many different
aspects and I think that my projects
provide a step in what I believe are the
right direction and supporting that kind
of work
for instance thinking about familiar
networks hive provides some patterns for
building those kinds of networks when
people don't know each other yet and
dynamo provides patterns for us to learn
about working with disagreements and
preserving momentum but they have
limitations so hive can help people who
are willing to talk to each other but if
people aren't willing to talk then
there's not much to do disagreements can
actually be very useful and they can
help people see any viewpoints and
dynamo and the labor of action can help
people move forward when those kinds of
things happen
but not if things have completely
derailed and there's still a lot more
work to do in this area other aspects of
collective action include making shared
decisions gathering and sharing
information creating a shared identity
supporting peripheral participation and
I plan to continue working on these
different aspects in the future thank
you and I look forward to your questions